so um welcome everybody uh to
the full
2020 online
uh introduction to the theory of
computing um 18404 6840.
my name is mike sipser
i'm going to be your instructor for the
semester in this class
um
so let me just tell you what the course
is about um
basically it's going to be into two
halves what we're going to be talking
about what are the capabilities and
limitations of computers of computer
algorithms really computation
um
and the two parts of the course are more
or less
divided in half
we're having the first half of the
course is going to talk about a subject
called computability theory
which it really asks what what you can
compute with an algorithm in principle
um
that's a was an active area of research
in the earlier part of the 20th century
it's pretty much closed off as a
research subject these days
mainly because
they answered all of their big questions
um and so uh a mathematical field really
only uh stays
vital when it has problems to solve and
they really solved all of their uh
interesting problems for the most part
not a hundred percent but for the most
part uh it sort of finished off in the
1950s um
just to say a little bit more about what
we're going to talk about there you know
when you're interested to know what
kinds of problems you can solve with an
algorithm
you know there are problems that you
might want to solve that you just can't
solve for example if you want to
you're given a specification for a um
you know a computer problem you want to
solve
whatever whatever that specification
might be say you know your algorithm
actually is a sorting algorithm for
example
and you want to write down that
specification and have an automatic
verifier that's going to check whether a
program meets a specification well
that's just in principle impossible you
cannot meet you cannot make a um
a verifier which is going to uh
answer in all cases whether or not a
program meets a certain specification um
so things like that we will prove uh
this uh this semester you know questions
about mathematical truth what if you're
given a mathematical statement is it
true or is it false uh it'd be great
if you can write a computer program that
would answer that problem well it would
not be great if you're a mathematician
because that would put us all out of
business but if you and you know
you could imagine that might be a nice
thing to have but you can't i mean there
is no algorithm which can answer that
question
um
uh well along the way we're going to
introduce models of computation like
fine automata which we'll see today
touring machines and some model other
models that we'll see along the way
the second half of the course which is
going to be after the midterm we're
going to shift gears and talk about
complexity theory which is instead of
looking at what's computable in
principle you're going to look at what's
computable in practice
so things that you can solve in a
reasonable amount of time
and um for example i'm sure many of you
are aware of the factoring problem which
has connections to uh the um
uh the the rsa crypto system you know
cryptography
um and asks whether you can
factor big numbers quickly um that's a
problem we don't know the answer to um
we just don't know how to factor big
numbers quickly but it's possible that
there are algorithms out there that we
haven't discovered yet that can do so
it's connected with this very famous
problem in the intersection of computer
science and mathematics called the p
versus np problem which many of you may
have heard of we'll talk about that
we'll spend a lot of time on that uh
this uh this term
and along the way we'll talk about
different measures of uh complexity of
computation time and space
time and memory
you know a theorist called memory i like
to call space
that's going to be a big part of the
course
in the complexity theory part introduce
other models of computation such as
probabilistic and interactive
computation
uh talk about the expectations of the
course first of all prerequisites
um
you know there are a bunch of
prerequisites listed you know
6042 18062 or maybe some other subject
as well
the real thing is is that this is a math
class
this is a class where i'm exp you know
and it's not a beginning math class this
is you know a moderate to advanced math
class and i'm expecting people to have
had some prior experience
you know of a substantial nature with um
mathematical theorems and proofs um
you know we'll start off slow but we're
going to ramp up pretty fast so if you
haven't really
you know got the idea or gotten
comfortable with doing proofs coming up
with proofs to mathematical statements
you know that's going to be a concern um
you can you know i would just be
monitoring yourself and seeing how
you're doing
because the homeworks
and the exams are going to count on your
being able to produce proofs um
and so
uh you're gonna stroke be struggling if
if that's gonna be a real uh something
that you haven't had experience with um
so and let me talk a little bit about
the role of theory um
in computer science is this a theory
class
um as you know um
[Music]
so
um
you know before we jump into the
material i just thought it would be
worth for you to give you at least my
perspective on the role of theoretical
computer science within the the
the field uh so you know i've been in in
in
in computer science for a long time you
know i go back i'm sure i'm getting to
be a dinosaur here but i go back to the
days when you had punch cards that's
what we did when i was an undergraduate
and um obviously things are very
different now um
and you can argue that in some you know
that you know computer science as a
discipline has matured and sort of the
the basic stuff has all been solved um
well i would say there's a certain truth
to that but there's a certain way in
which i would say that's not true um i
think we're still at the very beginning
and at least in certain respects of
computer science as a discipline
uh for one thing there are a lot of
things that we do um
uh a lot of things relating to
computation that you know we just don't
know the answer to very fundamental
things you know
you know let's take in this example how
does the brain work
obviously the brain computes in a
certain fashion um
but um
you know and we've made good progress
you can argue with machine learning and
all of those things which that are
really doing very
you know have very uh very powerful and
doing very cool things but i would also
say that
you know at some deeper level we really
have
you know the
the the um the methods that we have so
far
uh don't allow us to understand um
uh creativity um
you know
we're not close to being able to create
a computer program that can do
mathematics or that can do many of the
creative kinds of things that human
beings can do um
you know their i think machine learning
powerful as it is is really successful
only for a very narrow set of tasks um
and so
i think you know
there's a lot
i think there's probably something
deeper and more fundamental going on
that we're missing um that would be my
hunch um now whether something like um
theoretical computer science is gonna
give you an answer there or this kind of
theory or some kind of theory i think
some kind of theory has a as at least a
decent shot at playing a role in helping
us to understand computation in a deeper
way
and the fact that we can't understand
something as basic as can you factor a
big number quickly or not um you know
you can't really say you understand
computation until you can answer
questions like that
so i would argue that we have a really
very primitive understanding of
computation at this stage and that there
is a um a lot that has yet to be
discovered um not just on the
technological side but just on the very
fundamental theoretical side that has a
real shot at playing a role in affecting
the practice of how we use computers
and so i i think for that reason again
i'm not sure what what kind of theory is
going to be the most useful but the the
theory we're going to cover in this
course is a particularly elegant theory
and it has already paid off in many
applications and in terms of our
understanding of computation and i think
you know there is um at least as a
starting point it's a good it's a good
subject to learn um
uh certainly i enjoy it and i've spent a
good you know good chunk of my my career
uh
doing that um
so um
uh let's move on then um and begin with
the um
uh
um
the
subject material um so we're going to
talk about um
uh models of computation as i mentioned
um you know we
we want to try to understand computers
and we want to understand what computers
can do but computers in the real world
are pretty complicated objects and
they're really not nice to talk about
mathematically
so we're going to talk about abstract
models of computers that are much
simpler but really capture just like
models in general capture the important
aspects of the thing we're trying to
understand um
and so uh
we're going to look at several different
kinds of models that vary in their
capabilities and and the way they
approximate the real
computers that we deal with every day
and
to start for starters we're going to
look at a very simple model called the
finite automaton
and um that's going to represent uh you
can think of it as representing a
computer that has a very small
amount of memory um
and a very limited and small amount of
memory and we're going to look at the
capabilities of those kinds of machines
and what's nice about them is that you
can understand them very well
um and so um
uh more powerful models that we're going
to look at later are going to be harder
to understand in in a deeper way um but
for these we can
we can uh develop a very
um
comprehensive theory and so that's what
we're gonna do for the next lecture and
a half
um so this is gonna i'm starting off
with an example
i'm presenting a fine art automaton as a
um
as a diagram we call it a state diagram
that is a bunch of has these circles and
lines and um
uh
labels on the on the lines and and also
on the on these circles so let what's
going on here so this is a finite
automaton i'm giving it the name m1
and it has um
uh
these circles are called states so in
this case there are three states q1 q2
and q3 those are the labels there
there are arrows connecting once states
with each other um so these are we'll
call transitions um
and they're going to tell you how to
compute with this device
and there's going to be a specially
designated starting state which is has a
an arrow coming in from nowhere um
and there are certs
other specially designated states called
accepting states and that's going to
have to do with how the machine computes
but those are the ones that have these
double circles um
and so the talking about the way it
computes
the idea is pretty simple um the input
is going to be some finite string of
zeros and ones in this case we might
have other types of symbols that are
allowed for other
um automata but the example that i have
here it's going to be zeros and ones um
and the way you compute with the thing
is you uh first put your finger which i
can't do um
on zoom so i'm going to use the pointer
you put your pointer on the starting
state the one that has the arrow coming
in from nowhere you put your first you
put your your
pointer there and then
uh you start reading symbols from the
input uh one after the next so let's
take an example here zero one one zero
one
so you start reading
those symbols and you follow those
transitions so you go zero this is and
you go back to the same state then you
go for the next symbol is a one so you
go over to this state from q1 to q2
um now you have another one that comes
in so now you're starting at q2 you have
another one so you follow its associated
transition so
if you notice every state has an
outgoing transition for one and another
outgoing transition for zero so there's
always somewhere to go
every time you read symbols from the
input so now you're at q2 you read that
next um the third symbol which is a one
that's going to take you over to q3
and now you have a zero which loops you
back to the where you were and another
one which looks you back to where you
were and uh because you ended up at an
accept um
that is an ex you you say we accept that
straight um so so that's going to be the
output of this um
a finite attempt on
for each string it's either going to
accept it or reject it so it's just a
binary decision that it's going to be
making sort of like a one or a zero
output but we're calling it accept or
reject
so this one here
because it ended up at the accepting
state is accepted but if you look at the
second example
0 0 1 0 1 so you're going to have 0
0
1
0
one
now we ended up at q2
that's not an accepting state
so therefore we say we reject this input
um
okay very simple um
and now for example one of the questions
you might want to ask given one of these
things is well which are exactly those
strings that the machine accepts um
and
uh
a little bit of thought will
help you understand that and the only
strings which are going to take you over
to q3 are those strings that have a 1-1
appearing somewhere along the way two
consecutive ones and you will end up at
the accepting state um
um you have to i mean i encourage you to
think about that uh for a minute if not
immediately obvious but those are the
strings that are going to be uh accepted
by these this machine
and we call that collection of strings
the language of the machine
um that so that
set a
of those strings that have a 1 1 for
this particular machine is the language
of m1
we also say that m1 recognizes that
language recognizes a
and and in terms of notation we write
that a is l of m1
a is the language of m1 so the language
of a machine is exactly the set of
strings that machine accepts
okay
so one of the first things we're going
to want to be able to do is take a
machine and understand what its language
is what's the set of strings that that
machine accepts another thing we might
want to do is given a language build a
machine which recognizes that language
um
so and then understanding what are the
class of languages can you get any
language from some machine or are there
going to be some languages that you can
do and other languages that you cannot
do so those are the kinds of questions
we're going to be asking about these
finite automata what kinds of things can
those machines do and what can they not
do
um
okay
here's our net here is our uh next
check-in
um
so let me um uh so wake up everybody
who's not paying attention a check-in is
coming um
so we have more questions though i can't
uh
can't keep are these three statements
equivalent what to be statements
um
at the bottom of the slide
yes
those three are equivalent a is a
language those mean the same thing not
only are they equivalent but they
they're just different ways of saying
the same thing um
uh that m1 recognizes the language the
same as saying that's the language of
the machine and that a equals uh that l
of m uh that's that's all
the same way of saying they all six of
one half a dozen over the other it's two
ways of saying the same thing okay so
let's pop up our poll
um
and get that started
uh
whoops
still showing the old one oh here we go
move it to the next
question
okay
okay so
you understand the question here
after reason where do we end up after we
read one zero one what state are we in
do we end up in state q1 q2 or q3
okay
go fast
this is a
okay so i think we got uh
pretty much converged here
i think uh almost everybody got it right
um
uh the answer is indeed um that you
ended up in state q2 because you go one
zero one and that's where you ended up
in state q2 so is the mach is this uh
string accepted no
because you didn't end up in an accept
state so this machine rejects one zero
one
okay um
[Music]
let's keep going
so
now um
[Music]
okay so now we gave it this informal
idea of a finite automaton we're going
to have to try to get a formal
definition now um which is going to be a
more mathematical way of saying it's the
same thing that i just said um
and
the reason for having a formal
definition is for one thing it allows us
to be very precise then we'll know
exactly what we mean by a finite
automaton and it should answer any
questions about what counts and what
doesn't count
it also is um
a way of providing notation um so it'll
help us describe finite automata and
sometimes there might be an automaton
where
you know the picture is just too big so
you might want to be able to describe it
in in in some mathematical terminology
rather than by giving a picture or maybe
you're going to be asked to give a
family of automata where um you know
there is going to be
a parameter n
associated with the uh class of
languages you're trying to describe with
the automaton and then it'll be more
helpful to describe it in this formal
notation rather than as a kind of a
picture because
it might be infinitely many pictures
that are being needed
um so you may maybe examples of that
will come up with now so we'll find out
automaton we call it a five tuple don't
be put off by that a five tuple is just
a list of five things so
uh finite automaton will
in our definition is going to have five
components
um it's going to have uh q
which is going to be a finite set of
states so it's going to be a list you
know finite
set which will designate as the states
of the automaton
sigma
is the alphabet symbols of the automaton
another finite set
delta is the transition function
that tells us how the automaton moves
from state to state those gives it
describes how those
transition arrows those arrows which
connected the states with each other
um it describes them in a mathematical
way instead of in terms of a picture um
and the way i'm doing that is with a
function so delta is a function which
takes two things so you know i'm hoping
you've seen this notation before i'll
help you through it once but um this is
the kind of thing i would expect you to
have seen already so when we have uh q
cross sigma so i'm going to give delta a
state
and an in
a state and an
alphabet symbol so q is states sigma is
alphabet symbols so you're going to get
a state and a and a
alphabet symbol and it's going to give
you back a state
so more
um describing it you know um
[Music]
kind of a
little bit more detail you're going to
you know delta if you give it
state q and symbol a
equals r that means q when you read an a
you go to r
so that's the way this picture gets
translated into a mathematical function
um which describes those transitions
and then now q 0 is going to be the
starting state so there's going to be
that's the one with the in arrow coming
in from nowhere and f is the set of
accepted accepting states so there might
be several there's only going to be one
starting state but there might be
several different or possibly even zero
accepting states that's all legal
when we have a finite automaton um and
so in terms of using the notation going
back to the machine that we just had
from the previous slide which i've given
you here again
let me show you how i would describe
this using this notation that comes out
of the definition so here is m1 again
it's this five tuple
where q now is the set q1 q2 group three
that's the uh the set of states
uh the input alphabet is zero one
it might vary in other automata um and f
is the set q3 which has only the element
q3 because this has just one except
state q3
okay um so i hope that's uh helpful um
oh of course i forgot the transition
function which here i'm describing as a
table
so the transition function says um
you know if you have a q1 and a if you
have a state
and an input alphabet you can look up in
the table where you're supposed to go
under the transition function according
to the um
the uh
the state and the alphabet symbol that
you're you're given so for example you
know if we were in state um
q2
um here getting a zero
then q2 goes back to q1 so that q2 on
zero is q1
but q2 on one here
is q3
okay so that's how that table captures
this uh this picture
okay
and it's just a function it's a rep wave
representing a function a a finite
function um
uh
you know in terms of uh this uh this
table here so i realize for some of you
this may be
uh
slow um we will ramp up on speed but i'm
trying to get us all together in terms
of the language of the course here at
the beginning um
okay uh so now um
let's talk about some more um
uh the computation
uh
a
uh
so strings and languages
a string a string is just a finite
sequence of symbols from the from the
alphabet um so don't
whenever this class
is not going to talk about infinite
strings all of our strings are going to
be finite um
uh there's other mathematical theories
of automata and so on that talk about
infinite inputs and infinite strings
we're not going to talk about that um uh
you know maybe
rarely we'll make it very clear we'll
talk about an infinite string but that's
going to be an exception
um and a language is a set of strings
that's the traditional uh
you know um
a way that uh uh people in this subject
refer to a set of strings they call it a
language really because this subject had
its roots in linguistics actually um and
they were talking about they're trying
to understand languages you know human
languages
um
so this is just a historical fact and
that's the terminology that stuck
okay so two special string a string a
special string in a special language um
the empty string is the string of length
zero this is a totally legitimate string
um that you we're going to run into now
and then and there's the empty language
which is the set with no strings
these are not the same
they're not even of the same type of
object
so don't confuse them with one another
i mean you can have a a set a language
which has just one element which is the
empty string that is not the empty set
that is a set that is not the empty
language that is the a language that has
one element in it with namely the empty
string okay so those are separate things
okay so here's a little bit of a a
mouthful here on the slide um defining
what it means for a an automaton to
accept its input accepts its input
string w
and we can define that formally and you
know it's a little technical looking
it's really not that bad
um
so if you have a your input string w
which you can write as a sequence of
symbols in the alphabet w one w two dot
dot w n so you know like zero one zero
zero one i'm just writing it out symbol
by symbol here
um
so what does it mean for the machine to
accept um that's that input so that
means that there's a sequence of states
in the machine
sequence of states and of members of
queue so these are
a sequence from q these are the states
of the machine
uh that have a certain prod that satisfy
these three properties down here
first of all
and i'm thinking about the sequence is
the the sequence that the machine goes
through
as it's processing
the input w
so
when does it accept w
if that sequence has the feature that it
starts at the start state
each state legally follows the previous
state according to the transition
function
so that says you know the
member of the sequence
uh
is obtained by looking at the previous
one the i minus first member of that
sequence of that the i
the i minus first state in that sequence
and then looking at what happens when
you take the ice input symbol
so as you look at the previous state and
the next input symbol you should get the
next state that's all that this is
saying and this should happen for each
each one of these guys
and lastly for this to be accepted
the very last member here where we ended
up at the end of the input so you only
care about this at the end of the input
you have to be in an accepting state
so you can mathematically capture this
notion of going along this path
um
and uh that's what i'm just trying to
illustrate that you know we could
describe all this very formally i'm not
saying that's the best way to think
about it all the time but that it can be
done
and i think that's something you know
worth appreciating um
okay um
so now in terms of again getting back
we've said this once already but in
terms of the languages that the machine
recognizes it's the collection of
strings that the machine accepts
every machine accepts ex might it might
accept many strings
but it always recognizes one particular
language
even if the machine accepts no strings
then it recognizes the empty language so
a machine always recognizes some one
language
but it may have many many strings that
it's accepting
and we call that language the language
of the machine
and that's the and we say that m
recognizes that language these three
things mean the same thing
okay and now important definition i try
to reserve the most important things or
the highlighted things to be in this
light blue color if you can see that
we say a language is a regular language
if there's some finite automaton that
recognizes it
okay
so there are going to be some languages
that have associated to them finite
automata that actually solve those
languages that recognize those languages
but there might be other languages and
we'll see examples where you just can't
solve them you can't recognize them with
a finite automaton those languages will
not be regular languages the regular
ones are the ones that you can do with a
finite automaton that's the traditional
terminology
okay so let's continue let's go on from
there so look a couple examples here
again is that same getting getting to be
an old friend that language that
automaton m1
uh
remember its language here is the set of
strings that have the substring one one
that is the um
that language a
now what do we know about a
from the previous slide
think with me don't just listen
a is a
regular language now because it's
recognized by some
automaton
so
all of the whenever you find a um
an automaton for a language a finite
automaton for language we know that
language that language is a regular
language
so let's look at a couple of more
examples so if you take the language
let's call this one b
which is the the strings that have an
even number of ones in them
so like the string
one one zero one
would that be in b
no because it has an odd number of ones
so the string one one one one has four
ones in it that's an even number so that
string would be in b the
the zeros don't don't matter for this
language so that string
um
this
of
of of
strings that have an even number of ones
uh that's a regular language
um and the way you would know that is
you would have to make a fine art
automaton that recognizes that language
and i would encourage you to go
and make that automaton you can do it
with two states it's a very simple
automaton but if you haven't had
practice with these i encourage you to
do that and i actually there are lots of
examples that i ask you to
solve at the end of chapter one in the
book and you definitely should spend
some time
playing with it if you're not
if you have not yet seen uh finite
automata before um you need to get
comfortable with these and be able to
make them uh so we're going to start to
we're going to start making some of them
but we're going to be talking about it
at a sort of a more abstract level in a
minute
um
uh basically the reason why you can you
can solve this problem you can you can
make a fine art automaton would
recognize is the language b
is because that finite automaton is
going to keep track
of the parity of the number of ones it's
seen before
this has two states one of them
remembering that it's seen an odd number
one so far or the other one remembering
it's seen an even number of ones before
and that's going to be typical for these
automata finite automata there's going
to be
several different possibilities that you
may have to keep track of
as you're reading the input
and there's going to be a state
associated with each one of those
possibilities
so if you're designing an automaton you
have to think about as you're processing
the input what things you have to keep
track of and you're going to make a
state for each one of those
possibilities
okay so
you need to get comfortable with that um
let's look at another example um
the language c where the inputs have an
equal number of zeros and ones
that turns out to be a not a regular
language
um so what in other words what that
means is there's no way to recognize
that language with a finite automaton
you just can't do it
that's beyond the capabilities of finite
automata
and that's that's a problem that's
that's a statement we will prove later
um
okay um
and our goal over the next uh
lecture or so is to understand the
regular languages which you can do in a
very comprehensive way um so we're going
to start to do that now
so first we're going to introduce these
this concept of regular expressions um
which again these are things you may
have run into in one way or another
before um
so if we have a uh
um
we're going to introduce something
called the regular operations
now uh
you know
you i'm sure you're familiar with the
um
the arithmetical operations like plus
and times
um those apply to numbers
now the operations we're going to talk
about are operations that apply to
languages
so they're going to take
let's say two languages you apply an
operation you can get get back another
language like the union operation for
example
that's one you probably have seen before
um
the union of two languages here is a
collection of strings that are in either
one or the other
um
so
but there are other operations which you
may not have seen before that we're
going to look at um the concatenation
operation for example so that says
you're going to take a string from the
first language and another string from
the second language and stick them
together
and
it's called concatenating them
and you do that in all possible ways and
you're going to get the concatenation
language from these two languages that
you're starting with a and b
the symbol we use for concatenation is
this little circle but sometimes we
don't often we don't we just suppress
that and we write the two languages uh
next to one another with the uh little
circle implied so this also means
concatenation over here
just like this does
and the last uh
last of the regular operations is the
so-called star operation which is a
unary operation that applies to just a
single language
and so what you do is now um you're
going to take to look get a member of
the star language you're going to take a
bunch of strings in in the original
language a
and you stick them together
any number of members of a you stick
them together
and that becomes an element of the star
language i will do an example in a
second if you didn't get that
but one important element is that when
you have the star language you can also
allow to stick zero elements together
and then you get the empty string
so that's always a member of the star
language the empty string
okay so let's look at some examples
let's let let's say a is the language
these are two strings here good bad and
b is the language boy girl
okay
now if we take the union of those two
we get
a
good bad boy girl
that's kind of uh what you'd expect um
and um
if uh
um now let's
take a look at the concatenation
um
now if you concatenate the a and the b
language you're going to get all
possible ways of having an a string
followed by all possible ways having a b
string so you can get good boy good girl
bad boy bad girl
um now uh
looking at the star
um
[Music]
well
that applies to just one language so
let's say it's the good bad language
from uh a
uh and so the
a star that you get from that is all
possible ways of sticking together the
strings from a um so for there are no
using no strings you always get the
empty string that's always guaranteed to
be a member of a
and then just taking one element of a
you get good or another element bad but
now two elements of a you get good good
or good bad and so on um or three
elements of a good good good bit good
good bad
and so in fact a star is going to be an
infinite language
if a itself
is um
uh
contains any
non-empty member so if a is the empty if
a is the empty language or if a contains
just the language empty string
then a star will be
not an infinite language it'll just be
the language empty string
but otherwise it'll be an infinite
language
i'm not even sure
okay uh i'm not
i'm ignoring the chat here i'm hoping
people are getting are you guys getting
your questions answered by rtas
how are we doing thomas uh one question
is are the supplies going to be posted
are the slides going to be posted
well um
uh the whole lecture is going to be
recorded um is it helpful to have the
slide separately i can post the slides
um
sure i'll
remind me if i don't but i'll try to do
that yes it is helpful i will i will do
that
um
yeah um
yeah i will post the slides just
thomas it's your job to remind me okay
um
[Music]
all right good uh so regular so we
talked about the regular operations
let's talk about the regular expressions
so regular expressions are just like you
have the arithmetical operations then
you can get arithmetic expressions like
you know one plus three
um times seven so now we're going to
make expressions out of these operations
first of all you have the more atomic
and things the building blocks of the
expressions which are going to be like
um
uh
elements of sigma
you know elements of the alphabet or the
sigma itself as as an alphabet symbol or
the empty string or the empty language
of the the empty empty language or the
empty string these are going to be the
building blocks for the regular
expressions we'll do an example in a
second
and then you combine those those basic
elements
using the regular operations of union
concatenation and star so those are the
these are the atomic expressions these
are the composite expressions so for
example
um if you look at the expression
zero union one star
so that we can also write that as sigma
star because if sigma is zero
uh and one then sigma star is the same
thing as zero union one is sigma is the
same as zero union one and that just
gives all possible strings over sigma
so this is something you're going to see
frequently sigma star means all pos this
is the language of all strings over the
alphabet we're working with at that
moment
now if you if you take sigma star one
that's gonna you just concatenate one
onto all of the elements of sigma star
and that's going to give you all strings
that end with a one
you know technically you might imagine
writing this with braces around the one
but generally we don't do that we just
single element sets single element
strings we write without the braces
because
it's clear enough without them and it
gets messy with them so sigma star one
is all strings that end with one
or for example you take sigma star
one one sigma star
that is all strings that contain one one
and we already saw that language once
before that's the language of that other
machine that we presented on you know
one or two slides back
okay um
right uh
yes so
um uh yeah but in terms of readings by
the way sorry to i don't know if it's
helpful to you for me to do these
interjections but the readings are
listed also on the homework
so
if you if you
look at the posted homework one it tells
you
which
which chapters you should be reading now
and also if you look at the course
schedule
which is also on the home page it has
the whole
course plan and which readings are uh
for which dates
so it's all it's all there for you
um
and so our goal here this is not an
accident that sigma star one one sigma
star
happens to be the same language as we
saw before from the language of that of
that finite automaton m1
um in fact that's a general phenomenon
anything you can do with a regular
expression you can also do with a finite
automaton and vice versa
they are equivalent in power with
respect to the class of languages they
describe
and that's one we'll prove that
okay
um
so you know it's got you know if you
step back for a second and just let you
let yourself appreciate this it's kind
of an amazing thing because fine at
automata with the states and transitions
and the regular expressions with these
you know operations of union
concatenation and star they look totally
different from one another they look
like they have nothing to do with one
another but in fact they both describe
exactly the regular languages the same
class of languages
um
and so it's kind of a cool fact that you
can prove that these two very different
looking systems actually are equivalent
to one another
um
can we get
empty string from empty set yet
there are a bunch of
uh exotic cases by the way so empty
empty language star
is the language where has just the empty
string
if you don't get that chew on that one
that means but that is a that is that is
true um
uh
okay let's move on
okay let's talk about closure properties
now we're going to start in doing
something that has a little bit more
meat to it in terms of we're going to
have our first theorem of the course
coming here and this is not you know
it's not a baby theorem this is actually
uh there's going to be some meat to this
and you're going to have to uh um
you know
you know it's not totally um
this is not a toy this is we're proving
something that has a real substance
and and the um
uh
the statement of this theorem says that
the regular languages are closed really
the class of regular languages are
closed under union closed under the
union operation
um so what do i mean by that
so you you know
when you say a uh collection of objects
is closed under on some operation that
means applying that operation to those
objects
leaves you in the same class of objects
like the you know the um
the
natural you know the the positive
integers the natural numbers
that's closed under addition because
when you add two you know
positive integers you get back a
positive integer
but they're not closed under subtraction
because you know 2 minus four you get
something which is not a positive
integer
so close means you leave yourself in the
collection
and the fact is that
uh if you look at all the regular
languages these are the languages that
the
fine automata can recognize
they are closed under the union
operation so if you ta you start off
with two regular languages and you apply
the union you get back another regular
language
and that's what the statement of this
theorem is i hope you can i hope that's
clear enough in the way i've written it
if a1 and a2 are regular
then a1 union a2 is also regular that's
what the statement of this is and it's
just simply that um
that's proving that the class of regular
language is closed under union so we're
going to prove that
so how do you prove such a such a thing
so you know the way we
we're going to prove that is you uh
start off with you know what we're
assuming so we're our hypothesis is that
we have two regular languages
and we have to prove our conclusion that
the union is also regular
now the hypothesis that they're regular
you have to unpack that and understand
what it what is that what does that get
you and
them being regular means that there are
finer automata that recognize those
languages so let's give those two
fighter automata names so m1 and m2 are
the two finest automata that recognize
those two languages a1 and a2 that's
what it means that they're regular that
these automata exist
so let's uh have those two atomic m1 and
m2 using the components as we've
described this you know the respective
state sets input alphabet transition
functions the two starting states and
the two collections of stepping states
here i'm assuming that they're over the
same alphabet you could have automata
which operate over different alphabets
it's not interesting to do that
it doesn't add anything the proof would
be exactly the same so let's just not
over complicate our lives and focus on
the more interesting case so assuming
that the two
input alphabets are going to be the same
um and from these two automata we have
to show that this language here the
union is also a regular language and
we're going to do that by
constructing the automaton which
recognizes the union that's really the
only thing that we can do um
so we're going to build an automaton out
of m1 and m2 which recognizes the union
language a1 union a2
and the task of m is that it should
accept its input if either m1 or m2
except
and now what i'd like you to think about
doing that how would how in the world
are we going to come up with this find
out automaton m
um
and uh
uh the way we do that is
to think about
um
how would you
do that union language
you know if i ask you i give you two
automata m1 and m2 and i say here's an
input w
um
are is w in the union language
that's the job that m is supposed to
solve and i suggest you try to figure
out how you would solve it first
i mean this is a good strategy for
solving a lot of the problems in this
course put yourself in the place of the
machine you're trying to build
and so you know if you want to try to
figure out how to do that you know
natural thing is well you take w you
feed it into
m1 and then you feed it into m2 and if
m1 accepts it great and you know it's in
the union and if not you try it in and
try it out in m2 and see if m2 accepts
it um
now you have to be a little careful
because you want to have a strategy that
you can also implement in a fine art
automaton
and
uh
and a fine art automaton only gets one
shot at looking at the input you can't
sort of rewind the input you feed it
first into m1 and then you feed it into
m2
and
uh
operate in a sequential way like that
that's not going to be allowed um in the
way uh a finite automata work
so
you're going to have to be a little bit
more take it to the next level be a
little bit more clever and instead of
feeding it first into m1 and then and
then into m2 you feed them into both in
parallel
so you take m1 and m2 and you run them
both in parallel on the input w
keeping track of which state each of
those two automata are in
and then at the end you see if either
one of those machines is in an accepting
state and then you accept
so that's the strategy we're going to
employ um
in building the finer automaton m out of
m1 and m2 so here's in terms of a
picture here's m1 and m2
here is the automaton we're trying to
build
uh we don't know how it's going to look
like it and uh yeah so kind of getting
ahead of myself but here is the strategy
as i just described for amp
um
we're going to keep track
m is going to keep track of which
state that m1 is in and which state m2
is in at any given moment as we're
reading the symbols of w we're going to
feed it also into m1 and also into m2
and so
the possibilities we have to keep track
of in m
are all the pairs of states that are in
m1 and m2 because you're going to really
be tracking m1 and m2 simultaneously so
you have to remember which state m1 is
in and also which state m2 is in and so
that really corresponds to a pair of
states to remember
one from m1 and one from m2 and that's
why i've indicated it like that so m1 is
in state q m2 is in state r at at some
given point in time and that's kind of
correspond to m being in the pair q
comma r
that's just the label of this particular
state of m that uh we're gonna
apply here
okay
and so um and then
uh am is going to accept if either m1
and m2 so is an accepting state so it's
going to be if either q or r is an
accepting state we're going to make this
into a
an accepting state too
okay
whoops there we go
um
[Music]
so let's describe this formally instead
of by a picture because we can do it
both ways and sometimes it's better to
do it one way and sometimes the other
way
so now if we take uh the components of m
now
are the pairs of states from m1 and m2
again i'm writing this out literally uh
explicitly here but you should be make
sure you're comfortable with this cross
product notation
so this is the collection of pairs of
states q1 and q2 where q1 is in the
state of the first machine q2 is the
state of the second machine
the start state is you start at the two
uh start states of the two machines um
so this is q1 q2 probably i should have
not reused the q notation i should have
called these r's not of them looking at
that but anyway i hope you're not
confused by reusing this q1 and q2 here
are the specific start states of the two
twos of the two machines these are just
two
other states representative states of
those machines
now the transition function for the new
machine is going to be built out of the
transition functions for the old
previous machines so when i have a pair
qr
and i have the symbol a
where we go which new pair do we get
well we just update the state from m1
and update the state from m2 according
to their respective transition functions
and that's what's shown over here
um
now let's take a look at the accepting
states for m
the
natural thing to do is look at the set
of pairs of states
where we have a pair of states
of the
pair of accepting states one from
um the first machine and one from the
second machine
but if but if you're thinking with me
you realize that this is not the right
thing
what is dfas
uh
did i recall them dfa somewhere
oh somebody else is probably doing that
in the chat
uh
the dfa you careful what notation you're
using we haven't introduced dfas yet uh
we'll do that next on thursday uh but
these are dfas these are just fine at
automata deterministic finite automata
that's why they're
why the d anyway so
this is actually not right because if
you think about what this is saying it
says that both
components have to be accepting
and you want either one to be accepting
so
this is not good this is a this would be
the wrong way of defining it
that actually gives the intersection
language and really kind of along the
way it's proving closure under
intersection which we don't care about
but might be useful to have in our back
pocket sometime in the future
um
in order to get closure under reunion
we have to write it this slightly more
complicated looking way which says
that
you know uh the pair what you would want
to have is either the first state is a
an accepting state and then any state
for the second uh element or any state
for the first element and an accepting
state for the second element
that's what it means to have the union
uh to be doing the union okay so let's
let's do uh oh here's a quick check in
um
[Music]
so let's let's do another poll here you
thought we we thought we were done with
these um
again
you know
oh
here we go so i i it was too complicated
to write it out in the poll so i
actually put it up on the slide for you
um
[Music]
so i'm all i'm asking is that m1 has k
states k1 states and m2 has k2 states
how many states does m have
is it the sum
the sum of the squares or the product
okay you have to think about what are
the states of m what do they look like
um
and
uh
come on guys
all right ending the poll
uh
sharing results
yes indeed
it is most of you got it correct it is c
the the product
because when you look at the number of
pairs of states
from m1 and m2 you need all possible
pairs and so it's the number of states
in m1 times the number of states in m2
so make sure you you understand that and
think about that
um to uh
to so that you're you're following um
and and
and get this
all right so um let's move on here
so we have another five minutes or so
let's start thinking about closure under
concatenation
so if we have two regular languages so
is um the concatenation language um
we're gonna try to prove that we won't
finish but we'll at least get our
creative juices going about it um so
we're gonna do the same scheme here
we're gonna
take two machines for a1 and a2 and
build a machine for the concatenation
language out of those two so here are
the two machines for a1 and a2 written
down um
[Music]
and here is now here is
uh
the concatenation language and i'm going
to propose to you a strategy
um which is not going to work but it
still is going to be a good intuition to
have
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
make a copy of m uh okay let's
understand what m is supposed to do
first
so m should accept its input so think
about this m is doing the concatenation
language so it's given a string and it's
an answer is it in the cat concatenating
the concatenation language
a1a2 or not
so it should accept it if m1 if there's
some way to divide w into two pieces
where m1 accepts the first piece and m2
accepts the second piece
uh
so the here would be the picture
okay and now um we have to try to make a
machine which is going to solve this
intuition so how would you do that
yourself
you're giving you w
and you can simulate m1 and m2
so
the natural thing is you're going to
start out by simulating m1 for a while
and then shift into simulating m2 for a
while
because that's what happens as you're
supposed to happening as you're
processing the input so i'm going to
suggest that in terms of the diagram
like this um
so we have here um
uh m1 and m2 copied here
uh
and what i propose doing is
uh connecting m1 to m2 so that when
m1
has accepted its input we're going to
jump to m2 because that's perhaps you
know the first part of w and now we're
going to have m2 process the second part
of w so the way i'm going to implement
that is by
declassifying the start state of m2
having transition symbols from
the accepting states of m1 to m2
and then removing these guys here as
uh accepting states
and we have to would have to figure out
what sort of labels to apply here but
actually this reasoning doesn't work
it's tempting but flawed
because
what what goes wrong
what happens is that
you know it might be
that
when m1 has accepted an initial part of
w and then it wants m2 to accept the
rest
it might fail because m2 doesn't accept
the rest
and what you might have been better off
doing is waiting longer in m1
because there might have been some other
later place to split w
which is still valid
splitting w in the first place where you
have m1 accepting an initial part may
not be the optimal place to split w you
might want to wait later and then you'll
have a better chance of accepting w
of accepting w
so um
i don't i don't know sure if you quite
follow that but um uh in fact it doesn't
work the question is where to split w
and uh it's challenging because how do
you know where to split w because it
depends upon what you it's a it might it
depends on why and you haven't seen why
yet
so when you're trying to think about it
that way it looks hopeless
but in fact it's still true
and we'll see how to do that
on thursday
so
just to recap what we did today
um
we did our introductory stuff
we defined fine art automata
on regular languages we define the
regular operations and expressions
uh we showed that the regular languages
are closed under union
we start a closure under intersection to
be continued
you